well we've been talking to none other
than keanu reeves and that was just a
clip from what's going to be the biggest
movie of the year the matrix
resurrection
[Applause]
i have had the privilege of seeing it
too which i'm so grateful and it really
is that mind game
that you would almost hope a movie like
the matrix would provide but it does and
then some oh wow cool thank you yeah i
mean
um i mean it's also a love story right
you know trinity
thomas anderson neo fighting for their
lives what's real what's not
wake up
fight against the machines
you know i mean i think we can all
relate to that that's what's so crazy
right the themes are so human it is the
metaphor of humanity embedded in the
coding and it just
poses all these extraordinary questions
but
is it true that maybe at the end of the
day
it is about love
if it's not we're in trouble
yeah we're in big trouble i agree yeah i
better get that love on or you know
we're gonna we're not gonna make it i
mean we can say that interpersonally we
could say that as a species we could say
it as a planet
well
can i ask you uh because you are in fact
a true gentleman we wanted to learn some
etiquette from you so if it's okay we're
gonna play a little game called what
reeves believes of course
um okay we're going to give you a couple
fake scenarios but really they're
actually going to help us in real life
someone cuts you in line um speak up or
say nothing
what's the line
like grocery store is it like okay um i
guess it really depends on the the
um
what you know sometimes it's you just go
like whatever go cut the line you don't
know why they're cutting the line maybe
they need to cut the line maybe it's the
airport and they need to catch the
player maybe there are you know there's
circumstances that if you can take it
take in as much as you can and make a
decision i guess so
so it's not necessarily
hey man what the
what if you're just like in a movie
theater line and everyone's just
standing there and you know someone just
like cuts in in front of you
i think sometimes you have to make
executive decisions
[Laughter]
you know what i don't disagree that it's
a case-by-case basis i definitely
have become more zen and would surmise
the situation and think i don't know
what this person is going through in
life you're right like let me hold back
and i've had a lot of scenarios where i
just barked before i even thought
and i have such a rebel inside of me
because i the reason i love your
reputation so much is because i want to
live my life by that like that's really
important to me
is to be a good person like at my job
with my kids with my friends in no such
order but there's a problem i have with
rebellion and authority
is good it is it is of course you can't
just kick out rebellion
rebellion is usually a thoughtful
gesture
even though it feels so impulsive yeah
but it feels good yeah
and if you're barking and you know it
just it depends on what you do with your
bite i'm not a biter i'm a barker yeah
so you know
i'm not a fighter i'm a lover i don't
know no because if you're a lover you
got to be a fighter
how so
because if you don't fight for your love
what kind of love do you have
[Applause]
drew barrymore
getting all philosophical oh i love it
you are so loved
you are so respected you are so
appreciated and admired i was so excited
to see you yeah it's great to see you
too it's like
really special thank you thank you so
much for coming here yeah thank you
thank you
and of course i'm so excited about the
mind-blowing that will not let you down
we'll meet every expectation and exceed
them yet again
the matrix resurrection premieres
december 22nd in theaters and on hbo max
and everyone will be there for it
[Music]